[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers
my friends this is gunjan here welcome
to my 10th episode of
queen trap sack lines in this episode
i am going to show you a wonderful high
profile
attacking line against the symmetrical
english
where you can actually trap black's
queen
the critical position arises after the
following move order
c4 c5 here it doesn't matter whether or
white continue with
knight to c3 or g3 let's say
in this game white plays a g3 first
and after g6 bishop to g2
bishop to g7 knight to c3 and the moon
knight to c6 we have a copycat
symmetrical english on the board which
is in fact
one of the most popular choice by the
black camp
now against this i am going to propose
this
very cunning and tricky move a3
and if you check this position in online
database
black's one of the most frequent choices
e6
which has a very simple idea as he wants
to play
knight g to e7 and then later on
hit back in the center with d5
where this black bishop remain on a
pause
well everything looks so cool except one
problem that
white has this nasty pawn sacrifice line
starting with b4
if you see this position first time you
will be
amazed that the correct move in this
position is
knight captures b4 however even after
this
the game remain completely balanced
but more often than not you will find
out that
many of your opponent will take this
free pawn
with c captures b4 a captures b4
and knight captures b4
okay congratulations to black as he won
upon but
now the fun begins from the white side
with bishop to a3 kindly note that
black can never play the move a5 as
after bishop captures b4
this a pawn is so accordingly
again as per the database the most
frequent choice is
knight to c6 saving the piece
and asking why show me buddy
where is your compensation for loss of a
pawn
in fact there are more than 25 games
reached to this position
where after white's next reply knight to
b5
i think black is completely dead lost
the threat is very simple knight to d6
jack
and believe it or not but it is not easy
to parry there are three different
replies
tried by the black cam but none of them
are working number one
if your opponent continue with greedy
move
bishop captures even then
you can trap your opponent's queen and i
hope
you see it instantly yup
knight to d6 jack doesn't matter
wherever the king goes
the next move is knight captures b7
discover check to the king and attacking
the queen
so by force black is losing his queen
now amongst those 25 games more than 15
games
continue with knight g to e7
which has a very obvious idea black says
that
okay you can give me this check but i am
going to run away
and my extra pawn is going to count
later on
but guess what again this is a huge
mistake
as what has this lethal response
bishop to d6 so now the threat is very
obvious
knight to c7 check and grabbing the rook
in the corner
so again all of the games continue with
castle on the king's side so
that this knight doesn't come on c7 with
a jack
but unfortunately for black his queen
get the head shot after the following
sequence
bishop to c7 queen to e8
and now lovely knight to d6
which actually checkmate the black
queen
so this is one of the very high profile
quintra
exist in this symmetrical english
last but not least what happens if you
opponent continue with
bishop to f8 personally i think this is
one of the best response
and here white has many responses but
again
i like this very tricky move h4
and it sets up a cute trap if you open
and continue with a6
other moves doesn't make any sense for
example if
knight to f6 then we have this simple
line
knight to d6 jack bishop captures d6
and now bishop captures d6 gives white
this wonderful bishop which cannot be
dislodged
and because black king is stuck in the
center
white has all the time in the world to
generate an
onslaught and finish the game very
quickly
so let's see what is the big idea if we
open and continue with
a6 which looks very natural in this
position
getting rid of this pesky knight
but in fact white has this wonderful
trappy sequence
starting with h5 sacrificing
the whole piece
well who will resist not to capture a
piece
so let's check out what happens after
pawn takes p5
well now the sequence is very forceful
bishop captures f8 attacking the rogue
rook captures a1 attacking the queen
queen captures even
counter-attacking the black rook in the
corner
if queen to f6 then the simplest
response is
queen takes knight takes and bishop to
g7
which wins the piece and in fact the
game
so that is right out of the equation
the only correct move in this position
is
king captures f8 but even after this
we can simply take the rook in the
corner
and if you carefully check the material
at the 14th move of the game
white obtain an exchange which
with the accurate play more than
sufficient to get
the full point
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile queen trap in the
symmetrical english
remember when your opponent continue
with knight
g to e7 give him this root shock
with bishop to d6 castle
and now this cute sequence bishop c7
queen eight and knight to d6
telling black dare not to play a game
this opening thank you for watching this
video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care